[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avec à la une
cette semaine 600 km à pied pour
rejoindre Paris c'est le défi que c'est
lancé un maire de Gironde son objectif
se faire entendre et trouver des
réponses à ces problématiques de merde
petite commune comme nous l'expliquera
TV 7 la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest dès
le début de ce journal un trésor
sous-marin en Martinique et la rédaction
de via ATV nous dévoilera les résultats
de fou ils archéologiques réalisées sur
des épaves des objets datant du XVIIIe
siècle ont été notamment retrouvés et
puis recyclé c'est ce qui c'est possible
après cet hiver de neige la chaîne 8
Mont-Blanc nous emmènera dans les locaux
d'une start-up qui exploite des skis usé
pour fabriquer du mobilier puis en fin
de journée à l'attention au trompe
l'oeil avec le body painting vos jeux TV
nous fera découvrir cette discipline
artistique qui utilise les corps comme
décor
600 km pour porter ses doléances c'est
le pari osé je vous le disais dans les
titres d'un maire de Gironde pour se
faire entendre a donc décidé de rallier
l'Élysée à pied objectif de cette
aventure pédestre défendre des thèmes
chers à sa commune et rester pour leur
sans réponse un périple qui use les
souliers comme a pu constater Ivan
brancher pour TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest
je fais attention de moins marcher sur
la route pour préserver mes pieds c'est
des petits détails que j'avais pas
forcément pris en compte au début après
quelques jours de marche Jérémy gaillard
commence à prendre les bons réflexes mon
projet il est né il est né en septembre
de l'année dernière je dis toujours
c'est la problématique de notre réseau
d'aide spécialisé aux élèves en
difficulté qui n'avait pas les
éducateurs spécialisés dans le secteur
c'est ça qui m'a fait dire il y a un
truc qui tourne pas rond il faut qu'on
trouve une solution la solution relier
Coudreau commune de 1150 habitants en
Gironde à l'Elysée en marchant un trek
de 650 km à travers le pays en
définissant certains critères évidemment
des critères de sécurité quand même qui
étaient d'éviter au maximum les
Nationales bien évidemment j'en ai
aucune mais les départementales aussi
quand c'était possible de les éviter
durant ces jours de congés le jeune
maire et lui il y a trois ans effectue
entre 30 et 40 km chaque jour un rythme
effréné qui nécessite une bonne
hydratation et un bon sommeil j'ai
essayé de prioriser l'accueil par mes
collègues des communes où je m'arrête
donc je leur ai fait un courrier sur les
sur les communes où j'ai pas encore eu
de retour où j'ai pas de d'éléments j'ai
travaillé avec le réseau un réseau
d'élus et des soutiens décisifs pour
venir à bout de son objectif porter sur
la table des ministères 10 dossiers clés
qu'il a lui-même géré je suis pas fan de
l'agressivité je pense que manifester et
envoyer des courriers polis aujourd'hui
ça ne fonctionne pas quel que soit la
personne qui m'écoute que je souhaite
c'est pas qu'on fasse de l'affichage
c'est que on est des réponses concrètes
donc est-ce qu'on peut avoir plus de
gendarmes sur notre brigade est-ce qu'on
peut avoir les éducateurs spécialisés
qu'on a pas est-ce qu'on peut faire en
sorte en fin de mettre les moyens pour
que nos bords de fleuves et de rivière
soit entretenues voilà des demandes qui
pourraient trouver réponse le 7 juin
prochain le jour où Jérémy gaillard
devrait arriver au Palais de l'Élysée en
début d'après-midi
voilà un projet bien courageux porté par
cette édit les qui nous permet d'évoquer
maintenant l'une des principales
problématiques rencontrées par les
collectivités à l'approche de la saison
estivale la chasse aux fuites d'eau la
sécheresse de l'an dernier est celle qui
s'annonce pousse les communes à
surveiller leur canalisation dans les
roses cette tâche est rendue possible
grâce à une technologie innovante les
explications d'Elliott francum pourvient
Occitanie regardez
c'est une petite boule pas plus grande
qu'une balle de tennis qui est envoyée
dans les canalisations à une vitesse de
60 cm par seconde elle va analyser les
deux kilomètres de tuyaux de la ville
poche d'air petite et grande fuite tout
est détecté sur son passage dedans elle
est équipée principalement d'un
microphone c'est ce qui permet de
détecter les fuites puisque c'est un
bruit de sifflement c'est une dépression
et pour après les localiser on utilise
des capteurs qui sont sur la
canalisation qui sont géolocalisés au
GPS et là c'est un vol est doté d'un
émetteur de son un ultrason que le
capteur reçoit pour vérifier qu'elle ne
sait pas coincée dans les canalisations
6 points de contrôle ont été mis sur son
passage à l'aide de l'ordinateur Yann
peut vérifier la position en direct on
va avoir donc là des premières notions
de distance donc là elle serait aux
alentours de 100 mètres donc en amont et
au fur et à mesure les points vont se
rapprocher et une fois qu'elle aura
passé le coin de contrôle moi je l'aurai
une distance quasiment proche de zéro
qui permettra de confirmer qu'elle est
bien passée plus d'une heure après la
boule ressort dans ce réservoir d'eau
les données vont maintenant être
analysées au Canada ou à Singapour les
résultats sur les éventuels fuites d'eau
seront ensuite transmis à la
collectivité dans un mois l'intérêt
justement en période de sécheresse comme
en période ordinaire c'est de pouvoir
faire une inspection des canalisations
sans avoir d'impact sur les usagers donc
ça va être transparent pour les usagers
et on va avoir une analyse très fine de
toutes les problématiques qui sont
concernées par ce tronçonne canalisation
une opération qui a un coût près de
42000 euros ont été déboursés pour cette
détection et la course aux bonnes idées
pour préserver l'eau nous conduit en
Bretagne là-bas aussi des solutions sont
déployées pour lutter contre les effets
de la sécheresse dans la commune de
Saint-Lunaire par exemple ce sont les
eaux vidangées qui vont être utilisés
pour nettoyer la ville les détails avec
ce reportage de la chaîne TVA regardez
au pied du château d'eau de
Saint-Lunaire une réserve d'eau
secondaire enterrée fait l'objet chaque
année d'une vidange obligatoire pour
raison sanitaire mais à chaque fois il
fallait gâcher le fonds de la cuve soit
tout de même plus de 120 mètres cubes
alors cet hiver suite à la sécheresse de
l'été dernier il a été décidé de
conserver cette oppression et donc on a
recréé un réservoir de d'environ 200
mètres cubes dans un ancien ancien
réservoir de Saint-Lunaire construit en
1914-1917 donc là on a eu cette
possibilité on l'a on l'a travaillé avec
les services techniques durant l'hiver
le réservoir le voici construit derrière
ce petit muret sur une surface de 25
mètres sur 12 cet eau va être utilisé
dans le cadre du balayage puisque une
balleuse consomme à peu près 500 litres
d'eau toutes les deux heures donc on va
pouvoir balayer les Russes qui n'a pas
été le cas l'été dernier du fait de
l'arrêter sécheresse et on va également
pouvoir l'utiliser dans le cas de
l'hydrocurage autant potable qui ne sera
pas puisé sur le réseau ainsi
Saint-Lunaire utilise une eau de vidange
pour éviter de gaspiller et à sa lunaire
chaque goutte d'eau est précieuse
puisque les touches de plage ont été
stoppées depuis 2012 on anticipe ce qui
sera dans le rapport du GEC il
sécheresse tous les deux ans donc c'est
aujourd'hui qu'il faut faire les travaux
les aménagements et penser à économiser
à tous les niveaux la ressource en eau
devient stratégique Saint Lunaire et ses
2500 habitants consomment 400 mètres
cubes d'eau par jour en période
hivernale mais ces trois fois plus l'été
avec les touristes
et vous savez il n'y a pas que la
ressource en eau qui est précieuse en ce
moment chaque euro dépensé est aussi
scruté dans un contexte de hausse des
prix pour vous aider à faire vos courses
des applications se proposent de vendre
à moindre frais des paniers anti-gaspi
parmi celles-ci la plateforme Phénix
crée il y a quatre ans permet de retirer
en magasin des fruits et des légumes à
prix défiant toute concurrence un sujet
de Jérôme ouvrant pour oui au TV la
chaîne de la Voix du Nord et du Courrier
Picard
ces jours de course pour Aurélie qui
vient faire le plein du réfrigérateur
en quelques secondes l'affaire est dans
le sac aujourd'hui vous avez deux choux
un chou frisé un chou-fleur vous avez
une barquette de fraises il y a des
pommes il y a des bananes vous avez
d'autres légumes on a de l'ail dans ce
panier des fruits et légumes qu'elle a
réservé par avance via Phénix une
application mobile produit d'une startup
française
c'est une application avec plusieurs
enseignes donc vous sélectionnez
l'enseigne que vous vouliez prendre le
panier voilà j'aimerais vous venir le
récupérer mais du coup c'est moins cher
il y a d'autres enseignes qui font
différemment
des produits invendus ou à date de
consommation courte a pris cassée une
astuce anti-gaspillage aussi bonne pour
la planète que pour le porte-monnaie et
sur laquelle surfe de plus en plus
d'enseignes c'est des produits qui sont
un petit peu un petit peu moins jolies
ça va être une poire qui va être un
petit peu abîmée un petit peu Poké des
choses comme ça c'est des paniers qui
sont vendus à moins 50% en réalité du
prix de vente des produits chinois moins
50%, une aubaine face à la hausse des
prix notamment des denrées alimentaires
seules conditions sinequanone pour en
profiter il faut savoir se laisser
surprendre
vous acceptez en fait d'avoir ce cadeau
entre guillemets pour moins 50 - 60 - 70
% c'est intéressant économiquement pour
vous mais les règles du jeu c'est que
vous ne savez pas ce que vous récupérez
alors bien sûr si vous allez chez un
primeur vous aurez des fruits et légumes
vous vous en doutez mais vous ne savez
pas exactement lesquels puisque ce sont
les invendus du jour donc par nature ils
ne sont pas prédictibles pour le
commerçant pourtant le modèle carton
partenaire de la plateforme Phénix
depuis février cet enseigne à miénoise a
déjà vendu plus de 320 paniers anti
gaspi
à La Madeleine était l'invitée jeudi
matin de l'émission Face au territoire
sur TV5 Monde l'ancien député et
ministre de l'économie et des finances
s'est vu interroger sur la situation
politique et économique du pays regardez
cette extrait il y a plein de gens qui
accusent ou qui disent que Emmanuel
Macron est un président libéral ultra
libéral néolibéral vous partagez cet
avis écoutez si la France était libérale
nous n'aurions pas ce poids de
l'administration nous n'aurions pas ce
poids de la bureaucratie et nous aurions
pas ce poids des impôts et des dépenses
publiques nous sommes à la limite
presque recordman du monde dans les
démocraties non libéral alors Macron
Macron il est bien il a compris que pour
la croissance il fallait débrider
la fiscalité faire en sorte que les gens
aient plus d'argent de motivation à
gagner de l'argent c'est vrai mais en
même temps plus d'argent ensuite pour
pour l'investir qu'il avait besoin de
davantage de concurrence parce qu'il est
pour la concurrence c'est déjà beaucoup
c'est déjà beaucoup mais ça ne fait pas
un président libéral face au territoire
avec à la Madeleine et avoir ou revoir
sur le site internet de TV5 Monde et des
partenaires de l'émission Ouest-France
Nice-Matin france-ive 20 minutes la
montagne et le magazine Le Point le
point justement qui publie cette semaine
une édition spéciale consacrée à la
ville de Nice l'hebdomadaire propose
notamment un dossier sur les riches
naturelles de la région entre parc
naturel du Mercantour et train des
merveilles quelques bonnes adresses
niçoises vous sont aussi dévoilées dans
cette édition tout comme les clés du
marché immobilier local toutes ces
informations et d'autres sont donc à
retrouver chez votre marchand de
journaux dans le magazine Le Point dédié
à Nice allez sans transition direction
la Martinique dans ce journal ou des
passionnés d'archéologie viennent de
dévoiler les secrets d'un trésor sous
-marin une découverte réalisée sur des
épaves et pourtant sur une cinquantaine
d'objets datés du 18e et du XIXe siècle
les fouilles débutées il y a un mois ont
été réalisés grâce notamment à un
partenariat avec les forces armées un
reportage de Loïc Régis pourvient à TV
tout a commencé l'an dernier avec la
découverte de ce canon en bronze puis
les chercheurs relancent l'expédition
dans la baie de Fort-de-France en mai
2023 il trouve un gouvernail et sur
environ 100 mètres carrés une quantité
assez importante d'objets un résultat
présenté ce matin ou force à Louis
faïence pièce de monnaie ou encore des
accessoires présents sur un navire le
mobilier qu'on a prélevé dans le cadre
de ce projet date principalement de la
seconde moitié du 19e siècle donc on a
retrouvé des pièces de monnaie qui sont
datables de manière assez précise donc
des années 1850 avec les fichiers de
Napoléon III sinon on a du mobilier
aussi qui date du début du 20e siècle
après tant d'années passés sous l'eau
ils doivent maintenant livrer leurs
secrets ces objets sont importants parce
que vont nous permettre de donner des
fonctions aussi donc sur
[Musique]
leur utilisation que ce soit du mobilier
lié à la construction un navire à la
réparation des navires
aux équipages à la vie quotidienne à
bord chaque pièce collectée et
photographie des centaines de fois les
clichés sont analysés par un logiciel
afin de restituer une image en trois
dimensions avec ce procédé là on peut
continuer à faire l'analyse de l'objet
avec des milliers de photos chaque photo
sera parfaite et elle sera prise à un
mètre ou de distance et l'assemblage de
ces photos peut reconstituer l'objet ou
l'épave de manière très propre fragile
hors de l'eau et ne pouvant pas être
traités en Martinique la majorité des
objets seront replacés à l'endroit
précis où ils ont été prélevés la
mission sous-marine devrait être
reconduite l'an prochain si le
financement est approuvé
voilà et de trésors culturels il en est
aussi question à Saint-Étienne ou le
Musée d'Art Moderne est contemporain se
prépare à d'importants travaux une
rénovation qui oblige les agents du
musée à déménager les 3000 œuvres du
site une opération évidemment minutieuse
et risquée où tout doit être pensé pour
protéger les tableaux les sculptures et
les autres objets d'éventuels accidents
bien sûr un sujet de ces inertie il y a
pour TL7 la chaîne de la Loire
des salles vides et des murs immaculés
un spectacle un peu fantomatique auquel
le public n'est pas habitué au Musée
d'art moderne et contemporain les œuvres
ont été décrochées elles vont être
préparées pour le déménagement avant
travaux un travail minutieux réalisé en
partie dans cet atelier 3000 œuvres
peintures sculpture photographie entre
autres vont devoir sortir du musée il
reste quelques mois pour organiser ses
déplacements tout en garantissant la
sécurité de chaque objet effectivement
il faut arriver à manipuler ses œuvres
avec le plus grand soin possible
évitez évidemment toutes les vibrations
qui pourraient leur porter préjudice les
chocs et au fond de notre réserve étant
déjà saturé la problématique
est en fait d'avoir du recul de
manipuler comme il faut et donc des
d'éviter en fait tout risque d'impact
sur la plupart de nos œuvres mais le
challenge ne fait pas peur aux
spécialistes du musée plusieurs agents
ont été formés pour l'occasion et depuis
plusieurs mois mois on déborde
d'ingéniosité pour optimiser le stockage
tout en étant écologique et économique
en fait pour l'écologie c'était mieux de
vraiment pas mettre 6000 m² de bulle
c'est un très cher et très après ça va
direct à la poubelle alors que là c'est
du bois qui recyclable et puis quand
plus nous on peut recycler et l'avantage
c'est que pendant un an le stockage on
peut déplacer 10 15 œuvres en même temps
sur une seule palette
et on peut faire le suivi s'il y a une
dégradation sur chaque œuvre on a une
vision immédiate une fois préparée le
déménagement pourra débuter fin
septembre prochain les oeuvres sont
répartis dans des dans des lieux
différents à Saint-Étienne il y a les
réserves historiques du musée avec soit
Saint-Jean-Bonnefonds ou à côté de la
Cité du Design et puis là nous nous
louons des espaces supplémentaires pour
accueillir les oeuvres qui sont
habituellement le stocker au musée la
phase de travaux débutera ensuite pour
une réouverture estimée au printemps
2024 mais certaines œuvres du musée
seront encore visibles hors les murs
dans une prochaine exposition à la Cité
du Design exposition qui lancera le
projet de Galerie nationale du design
de la réalité virtuelle pour les seniors
à Limoges un atelier découverte était
organisé il y a quelques jours dans l'un
des EHPAD de la ville une technologie
qui permet aux résidents de voyager dans
leur passé ou de découvrir de nouveaux
endroits une activité qui a aussi pour
but de créer des échanges de stimuler la
motricité et aussi de favoriser
l'apaisement de nos aînés l'image et
explications de Benjamin Delmas pour cet
aliment ils sont captivés par le film et
donc
ils sont beaucoup plus détendus après et
plus calme et plus plus ouvert à
l'échange quoi c'est la première fois
que vous mettiez un casque comme ça
première fois oui première fois oui et
ça fait un peu peur de mettre un casque
comme ça ou pas du tout pas du tout peur
non non c'est impressionnant mais c'est
tout ou non ça ne fait pas peur non pas
du tout non
que faire des skis usagers après la fin
de saison hivernale voilà une question
bien encombrante avec le retour des
beaux jours depuis trois ans une
entreprise savoyarde c'est donc lancer
le défi de recycler nos vieux skis en
France en moyenne 500 000 d'entre eux
sont jetés chaque année l'idée c'est les
réutiliser pour en faire du mobilier des
tabourets des tables ou même des abris
de bus une idée innovante est bonne pour
l'environnement comme a pu le constater
Camille Privat pour la chaîne 8
Montblanc sur place
dans cette entrepôt une montagne de ski
ici toutes les couleurs les marques et
les époques sont représentées c'est ce
qui ne sont pas destinés aux pistes mais
bel et bien à votre salon donc là ça va
être tout le gisement qu'on va avoir des
skis
avant le tri et la sélection donc comme
ils arrivent des déchetteries ce skatek
fabrique des meubles un peu particuliers
car c'est ce qui récoltait en
déchetterie sont utilisées comme matière
première une fois remis à neuf ils
seront transformés en table en tabouret
ou même en abribus made in Savoie
techniquement c'est un produit qui est
très performant donc on peut se
permettre pas mal de choses au niveau du
flex au niveau de la solidité du produit
ça légèreté et de sa ligne qui pour moi
c'est ouais on arrive sur quelque chose
de très élancé très coloré donc on peut
vraiment s'amuser avec ça ouais en
France ce sont en moyenne un demi
million de ski qui finissent à la
décharge chaque année l'entreprise s'est
lancé le défi d'en réutiliser 20% d'ici
2025 aujourd'hui c'est juste c'est
enfoui en décharge ou c'est réduit en
combustible solide de récupération parce
qu'on sait pas en fait c'est un sandwich
de divers matériaux
emballé dans de la résine et donc
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de solution de
recyclabilité choisir le bon modèle dans
leur stock de 12000 skis coupé nettoyer
lustré c'est un travail d'orfèvre que
les finitions correspondent à 20% du
travail total mais correspondent en
temps à 80% du temps pour les structures
les plus importantes comme les abris à
vélo il faut également réaliser une
série de tests pour identifier les
propriétés mécaniques en 2022
l'entreprise a permis de donner une
seconde vie après de 500 ski
maître l'ambiance et harguer la foule
pour aider son équipe à gagner voilà en
résumé le travail d'un speaker
professionnel au club de basket du Mans
cette tâche est assurée depuis 10 ans
par Vincent Royer cet ancien animateur
de radio fait preuve vous allez le voir
d'une énergie folle les jours de match
qu'on a en scène pour elle mtvart l'a
suivi le temps d'une rencontre regardez
est-ce que vous êtes prêts
cette voix le public dans ta race la
connaît par cœur Vincent Royer et maître
de cérémonie il anime différents
événements principalement du sport c'est
avec le club de volley de Poitiers qu'il
a commencé je suis devenu fan de ce club
supporter de ce club un peu ultra dans
le bon sens du terme et le manager de
l'époque m'a dit bah tiens tu fais plus
de bruit que tout le monde dans les
tribunes tu vas présenter les matchs la
saison prochaine et donc j'avais 16 ans
quand il en a parlé j'ai commencé
j'avais 17 ans depuis Vincent est devenu
l'un des speaker les plus reconnus de
France à son actif le robasket 2015
l'Euro de football 2016 ou encore le
match de NBA entre Chicago et D3 à Paris
en janvier un travail où il profite de
chaque instant les poils qui se dressent
sur les avant-bras c'est c'est pas
descriptible en fait comme sensation
quand on se retrouve au milieu de 5000
personnes 10000 personnes 30000
personnes on joue avec le public et on
prend une énergie qu'on doit rendre avec
le public et c'est hyper c'est hyper
euphorisant comme comme sensation son
travail intervenir assurer le son mais
aussi coordonné toutes les animations
avant chaque rencontre il s'entretient
avec le responsable communication du
club et les équipes techniques à
quelques minutes du début du match la
pression monte toujours il faut avoir le
même stress avant chaque match même si
ça fait des années que je suis au MSB
parce que parce que si tu ne mets pas la
même rigueur le soir de match et que tu
dis bon bah ce soir c'est bon je sais
faire c'est là où tout bien un truc en
fait faut s'obliger à être stressé
presque je dirais et après ce stress là
tu transforme en légère en énergie
positive depuis le parquet sa manière
d'animer et saluer souvent ça part de
l'huile la bonne énergie dans la salle
je pense qu'il recentre très bien les
moments où on a besoin de de la pluie du
public pour essayer de se surpasser
pendant les play-offs avec son speaker
endiablé et un public surchauffé Antares
pourrait redevenir un chaudron embrasé
tu y es maréchal-ferrant ou encore
tailleur sur pierre voilà certains des
métiers et savoir-faire presque disparus
en 2023 des traditions que tentent de
faire vivre une association en Moselle
c'était tel proposera tout un week-end
d'animation autour des métiers
d'autrefois une manière de préserver le
patrimoine culturel comme nous le
raconte Jonathan Vauché pour Moselle TV
on va commencer
en ligne vers là-bas le château de
Romécourt comme au début du 20e siècle
allons-y charpentier tailleur sur pierre
faucheur ou encore potier tous les corps
de métiers d'un village d'antan seront
reproduits durant un week-end
disparu et puis qui t'emmène à avoir un
certain et à regarder pour tout ce qui
est artisanat et l'artisanat d'art et le
travail de la terre dans cette ferme
fortifiée d'autrefois le public venait
déjà nombreux depuis deux saisons pour
assister au roman de romecourt un
spectacle nocturne son et lumière cette
année la journée entière sera consacrée
à faire revivre la vie de ce château
quand j'ai conçu le roman de mes cours
avec multifonctions c'était de faire ça
de reconstituer l'affaire c'est un peu
dévié j'ai raconté l'histoire de la
famille mais là on va davantage raconter
l'histoire du pays des étangs de la
Moselle comment ont travaillé autrefois
en plus de la ferme pédagogique les
enfants pourront découvrir des métiers
manuels comme la tonte de moutons ou la
boulangerie j'aime plus transmettre le
savoir que transmettre le pain même si
offrir du pain à quelqu'un ça donne
toujours le sourire mais c'est vrai
aussi faire comprendre aux gens que
acheter des des pains à 1 euro en
supermarché c'est impossible d'avoir une
qualité de travail ou une qualité de du
produit il était une fois remécourt se
déroulera le weekend du 19 et 20 août
avec l'aide de 85 bénévoles qui sont
déjà en pleine forme pour leur rôle
[Musique]
voilà de la couleur des trompe l'oeil et
des corps pour œuvre d'art pour terminer
ce journal la rédaction de Vosges TV
nous emmène dans les allées de l'un des
principaux rassemblements d'Europe
consacré au body painting une discipline
en plein essor et qui vous allez le voir
s'amuse des perspectives grâce à l'usage
des corps un reportage de Thierry Lasson
et Dan Didier
[Musique]
il était difficile ce week-end de passer
à côté sans les apercevoir et en même
temps il fallait tout de même bien
ouvrir les yeux c'est une technique de
camouflage ah c'est plus technique
technique
les Imaginales au parc du cours d'Épinal
se déroulait sur deux jours et comme
chaque année désormais les traditionnels
rencontrent de body painting pas si
traditionnel que cela
existe depuis déjà un moment c'est
quelque chose qui se pratique mais
jamais un événement à tel ampleur plus
d'une trentaine de modèles
essentiellement féminins avaient prêté
leur corps à autant d'artistes des
modèles femmes mais pas seulement
quelques hommes avaient fait de même
suffisamment rares pour être remarqué
c'est la première fois que que je suis
modèle et apparemment c'est plus sur les
femmes donc bah c'est cool du coup de
pouvoir représenter la diversité
masculine dans ce milieu et Alexis ne
s'est pas vraiment fait prier pour
laisser libre corps à son ami Morgane la
jeune femme dont c'était la toute
première fois qu'est-ce qui vous plaît
dans dans cet arbre
expression
un projet artistique en fait et puis
voilà c'est juste les patients du cœur
il y a pas d'autres explications pour
Lucie ce n'était pas une première en
revanche en tant que modèle photo mais
c'est vrai que là le body painting c'est
une deuxième expérience on va dire une
deuxième bonne expérience aussi un body
painting complet au niveau du corps
quant à l'artiste c'est l'illusion qu'il
inspirait mais au bout du compte
beaucoup de détails beaucoup de points
beaucoup de petits traits de de symétrie
aussi donc
c'est pas le meilleur choix mais bon on
saura pour la prochaine voilà sur la
photo c'est très dur de distinguer c'est
vrai que on ne les voit pas sur la photo
ou très peu mais en vérité l'appareil
photo n'a qu'un œil nous on en a deux
donc on voit la perspective donc on
arrive à les photographier
c'est la fin de cette édition merci
d'avoir suivi ce grand JT des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]